hello everyone i'm musan hong from brass
group at mit
i'm really honored to present about my
research at bioprocessing virtual event
today i'll present about my research on
macroscopic modeling of bioreactors
for recombinant protein producing
picapastorius in defined media
we begin with explaining
biopharmaceuticals which are also widely
known as biologics
they are products derived from
biological organisms for treating or
preventing diseases
the global sales of biopharmaceuticals
have continuously increased for many
years
and they are projected to reach about
450 billion dollars by last year
percentage of biopharmaceuticals in the
drug pipeline have also continuously
increased
resulting in hundreds of approved
products on the market
including monoclonal antibodies and
other recombinant products
and over 7000 medicines in development
traditional biopharmaceutical
manufacturing consists of a similar
sequence of bacterial patients
that are divided into upstream and
downstream for example the figure in
this slide
shows a process for a diagram for
typical platform
used for producing monoclonal antibodies
the upstream unit operations include
cell culture with a series of batch
bioreactors
and harvest steps which are
centrifugation and filtration in this
case
the downstream consists of purification
with multiple steps of chromatography
filtration and die filtration
there are several trends in
biopharmaceutical manufacturing
and these are providing important roles
for process system engineers like myself
first the growth of biologics increased
interest in applying process analytical
technology
p-a-t p-a-t is a system of analyzing
manufacturing
through the online measurements of
critical quality attributes
to ensure the final product quality
online measurements provide much more
data on the multi-variable interactions
and dynamics
and depending on the process
understanding these data have been used
to construct first principles
and database models for each of the unit
operations
another trend is a transition of many
processes from batch to continuous
operation
this batch to continuous transition
emerges a recent trend
of chemically dry pharmaceutical
manufacturing
for reducing manufacturing costs and
increasing productivity and quality
the continuous manufacturing processes
provide new process control problems
to handle the propagation of impurities
and other disturbances
caused by the tight integration of
continuous general operations
another area of interest is the
invention of new designs for protein
separations
currently the dominant method is picked
by chromatography due to its high
resolution
but this method is costly for high-dose
pharmaceuticals
so the non-chromatography separation
methods are becoming more attractive
as more than bioreactors are achieving
higher product titles
and criticization is one of the more
promising proposed technology
this will be a major shift in
biopharmaceutical manufacturing
and will involve new processes to be
controlled
my research topics deal with the
challenges related to these recent
trends in biopharmaceutical
manufacturing
and can be also divided into upstream
and downstream
for upstream i have constructed
mathematical models for multiple
bioreactor configurations
including microbiota systems and stir
tank bioreactors
and for downstream i'm working on
model-based design and control for
bioseparation processes
including continuous ground activation
and crystallization
in the entrance of time for today's talk
i'll be presenting the work
on macroscopic modeling of stir tank
bioreactors
start with bioreactor models in general
they are developed based on the data
received from the bioreactor ones
then these bioreactor models inform
understanding of cellular metabolism
such as growth kinetics productivity and
media consumption
these further understanding can be also
used to optimize the bioreactor
operations
which feeds back to the bioreactor runs
the bioreactor models are developed with
different levels of details and
complexity depending on their purpose
there are complex cellular models like
genomic scale metabolic models
which describe detailed cellular
metabolism
using the data on gene expression
however
these models have too many parameters
and most of the primaries are highly
uncertain
even with additional assumptions like
steady state metabolic fluxes
in contrast microscopic models give
reasonable description of the bioreactor
with simpler mathematical formulations
and low computational cost
these type of models can also facilitate
real-time application
such as adaptive primary estimation and
mild predictive control
cell consider for the bioreactor
modeling was pre-capacitors
pickup pastors as methotropic yeast
which is widely used as the microbial
host
recombinant protein production
the system has the advantages of
hydrogen regulation
and high productivity with methyl
induced alkyl oxides promoter
growth on simple media and high cell
density with preference for respiratory
growth
eukaryotic post-translational
modification
such as glee constellation and disulfide
conformation
and simplified downstream purification
with foreign protein secretion
a low amount of naturally secreted
proteins
in this work an extensive macroscopic
bioreactor model was constructed
not only for substrates biomass and
recombinant protein but also for other
medium components
and off gas components like oxygen and
carbon dioxide
modeling the medium components was
facilitated by using a chemically
defined medium
which also reduces run-to-run
variability and simplifies downstream
purification processes
additionally ph model was constructed
based on overall charge balance
acid-base equilibria and activity
coefficients
to describe the dependence of
recombinant protein production on ph
precipitation of medium components and
carbon dioxide to carbonate species
reaction
the mod parameters with those
uncertainty were collected from the
literature
and the distribution of uncertain
parameters were estimated
from the maximum likelihood method
looking into the model development
bioreactors have been traditionally
modeled as 13 chemical reactors
material balance is set up as the
equation in the slide
which is in terms of the concentration
of species of interest
in this equation delta term is a
separation factor
specifying the concentration in the
outlet for biomass concentration
delta term is equal to one for fed batch
operation
and zero for perfusion operation
our term is evolutionary reactional rate
including both biological and chemical
reactions
and biological reaction rate models can
be classified
as unstructured or structured and
non-segregated or segregated model
the macroscopic model was developed as
an unstructured and non-segregated model
which means that the cell population is
treated as single component
and all cells are considered to be
identical
differential balances for concentration
of biomass
substrates which are glycerol and
methanol and total proteins
including both recombinant protein and
wholesale proteins
are given as the equations on the left
of the slide
the specific growth rate is modeled to
be proportional
to the specific substrate consumption
rate minus the maintain coefficient
and the specific substrate consumption
rate is modeled with the most commonly
used monolith equation
the specific production and wholesale
protein secretion rates
are them together and model to be
proportional to the specific growth rate
also it was observed at the ph of the
medium
of vexitol protein concentration to
consider this effect of the ph
it was assumed that a hypothetical
enzyme is responsible for the secretion
of proteins
and it is only active in its original
deprotonated form
then the active portion of total enzyme
is described with the equation given in
the side
and its proportion is included into the
specific tool production
biomass composition of picket pastoras
has been reported from several past
studies
and there was a study which reported the
biomass composition
under different oxygenation conditions
as well as
under recombinant protein producing and
non-producing conditions
as we can see from the pots in the slide
the study showed that the control strain
resulted in fairly constant level
of protein and carbohydrate under all
oxygenation conditions
a recombinant protein producing strain
resulted in significant
increase in protein and decrease in
carbohydrate
as the oxygen availability decreased
this variation in macromolecular
composition led to increase in carbon
and nitrogen composition
at the same time extracellular and
intracellular content of recombinant
protein
also significantly increased when the
oxygen availability was reduced
these results suggest that the
recombinant protein production
is correlated with a variation in
macromolecular and chemical compositions
so concentrations of intracellular
carbon and nitrogen
are included as the states in the model
they were
and were modeled based on the mass
balance of biomass
and in this model the specific carbon
dioxide evolution rate
and specific nitrogen update rate were
modeled to be proportional to the
specific growth rate
moving on to the medium components rich
defy medium components
include total phosphate sulfate ammonium
glutamine and arginine species
and also potassium magnesium calcium
transition metals and chloride
the differential balances for these
components include the terms
for specific uptake rate and
precipitation in the solution
for nitrogen sources ammonium glutamine
and arginine
they can be utilized simultaneously by
pizza pastors
actual nitrogen regulation will be
complicated but here
we simplify the model so that the
nitrogen sources
are utilized based on their molar ratio
of nitration
with the components without nitrogen the
specific uptake rates are modeled
assuming the constant elemental
compositions
this is consistent with the results in
the literature
which reported constant sulfur and
nash's composition
under different operating conditions
and precipitation caused by medium
components is one of several common
problems
in the cell culture media so ph model
with precipitation was developed with
the medium components
for the general description acid-base
species are described as a
and remaining species are described as s
with subscripts meaning the different
species
then the base of ph model is from the
total charge balance
and acid-base equilibria for acid-base
equilibria
activity is applied instead of
concentration because ionic strength can
be high during the bioreactor operation
so the activity is modeled with the
davis equation
which is simple and known to be valid up
to 0.5 molar concentration of ionic
strength
precipitated species are described with
different precipitation reaction in the
side
and the differential balance is
formulated similarly with the medium
components
but with opposite sign for the
precipitation rate
precipitation rate is described with
given expression in the slide
and reaction rate constants are said to
be large number to assume
fast kinetics
for the gas phase of the bioreactor
there are homogeneously dispersed
bubbles
and has base gas above the liquid medium
these two gas phases can be modeled as
third tanks connected in series
but actually it is reasonable to lump
them as a sold gas phase
gas transfer between headspace and
liquid is negligible compared to the gas
transfer between bubbles and liquid
because of the order of main to smaller
surface area
so there is negligible difference
between two phases
then differential balance for
malfraction of oxygen and carbon dioxide
is expressed as given in this equation
the most important term that has to be
modeled in this expression
is the gas transfer
oxygen transfer is especially important
for systems with big capacitors
because of the high oxygen uptake rate
and high cell density
the bioreactor is designed to diffuse
oxygen from sparge bubbles into the bulk
liquid
oxygen transfer rate can be calculated
from differential balance for
concentration of dissolved oxygen
and scaling analysis shows that the term
with concentration of dissolved oxygen
can be neglected due to the low
solubility of oxygen in the medium
carbon dioxide produced from the cell
metabolism is diffused in the opposite
direction with oxygen
from the bulk liquid to sparge bubbles
carbon dioxide transfer rate can be also
calculated from differential balance for
concentration of dissolved carbon
dioxide
but the approximation that was used for
oxygen is not applicable because of its
high solubility
instead considering that the gas
transfer rate and volumetric mass
transfer coefficient
for oxygen and carbon dioxide are same
order of magnitude
concentration of dissolved carbon
dioxide can be approximated to a
saturated concentration
and unlike oxygen dissolved carbon
dioxide converts into carbon species
with the following chemical reactions so
these were also taken into account
in the model
the oxygen up peak rate metabolic flux
model was introduced
based on the division of metabolic flux
into anabolism
and energy metabolism
glycerol and methyl metabolism was
simplified as given in these reaction
networks
and oxygen yield coefficients for
anabolism and energy metabolism
were calculated from these reaction
networks
for primary estimation needed for the
model maximal likely estimation was
applied
maximal likely estimation is commonly
used in the literature
assuming that there exists a constant
parameter vector for all experimental
data sets
in this case the mole equation for the
system is expressed
as these equations and the maximum
likely estimation
is formulated as this minimization
problem
however in this work the primaries were
estimated
assuming that there exists a
distribution of parameters between
different experimental data sets
this was to describe the variations that
was observed between individual
experiments
even with highly similar target
operating conditions
with controllable temperature ph and
dissolved oxygen
in this case the model equation for the
system is expressed
with constant parameters for each of the
experimental data set
which have the following distributions
then
the variance for the states can be
approximately described
by a function of primary distribution
sensitivity and the measurement noise
and finally the maximum likely
estimation is formulated as this
minimization problem
optimizing with respect to both mean and
variance of the parameters
from here i'll present the results of
the macroscopic
macroscopic bioreactor model in the
bioreactor runs
it was observed that the precipitation
occurred
when base ammonium hydroxide was added
for peach adjustment
before the inoculation and magnesium
ammonium phosphate was identified as
candidate precipitate
because the medium component measurement
before and after the ph adjustment
showed that the ammonium and phosphate
are included in the precipitate
this plot shows the ph mod predictions
with precipitation
a solid line without precipitation as
dashed line
and experimental data as open circles
experimental data are ph measurements of
hd5 medium
as base among hydroxide is added
for the mild prediction acid
dissociation constants were taken from
the literature
and the solubility product was estimated
with these squares
and we can see from the plot that the ph
data of reach defined medium
at different phase concentrations are
well described by the ph model with
precipitation
experimental data also showed that the
precipitation occurred
when about point three to point four
percent of base was added
which again shows good agreement with
the model prediction
how long this slide shows a comparison
of macroscopic bioreactor model
predictions
with bioreactor-run data on biomass
concentration
again the solid line shows the mild
predictions
and the open circles show the
experimental data from the bioreactor
ones
vertical dashed lines represent times
when the operation will change
first from glycerol batch to cholesterol
fat batch
and then to methanol fat batch
fermentation was carried out with pigeon
pastures
p4 or pa serotype of a non-replicating
world of virus
dphdri to subunit vaccine
for operating conditions temperature was
25 degrees celsius
and ph was different round by run
varying between
4 and 6.5 also in some fermentation
a peach pulse was implemented at the end
of metal adaptation
this brought ph down to 3 to reduce the
degradation of protein by inactivating
proteases
primaries required for the growth and
substrate consumption
were taken from the literature and we
can see from the plot
that the biomass data with different ph
conditions
and different strains are well described
by the macroscopic model
parts on this slide show the comparison
of thermal predictions with data on full
protein concentration
the plot on the left shows the total
protein concentration
with the ph condition of each of the
bioreactor runs
given in the plot on the right
parameters for the total protein
production were estimated with a maximal
likelihood method
and we can see from the plots that the
total protein data are well described by
the microscopic model
but have more variability compared to
the biomass concentration
total protein production during glycerol
period is fairly consistent
since most of the proteins produced are
whole cell proteins
run term variability of total protein
production occurred
mainly during methylene period due to
the recombinant protein production
this may be described by the unmeasured
cell properties such as viability and
cockpit number variation
and ph dependence of the total protein
concentration is evident
from the concentration for different ph
conditions during the cholesterol period
and trend of the concentration before
and after the ph shift during the
methanol period
these tips this dependence suggests that
the lowering ph for inactivating
proteases
can actually negatively affect the
quantitative productivity
response on this slide shows a
comparison of the mod predictions
with data on concentration of medium
components
for phosphate ammonium data with low ph
conditions were only used
because of precipitation and higher ph
conditions
parameters for elementary compositions
were estimated with maximum likelihood
method
and estimated values reasonably agreed
with the values from the literature
the phosphate and potassium data are
well described by the microscopic model
which demonstrates that the constant
element of composition
is reasonable assumption
on the other hand ammonium data had more
one form variability compared to the
other medium components
again frontal availability of ammonia
consumption
occurred mainly during the methanol
period this is when the intracellular
concentration of nitrogen increased
due to the recombinant protein
production
for the gas phase the plus on this slide
show the comparison
of the model predictions with data on
off gas composition
of oxygen and carbon dioxide
primaries for carbon composition were
estimated with maximum likelihood method
an estimated value for initial carbon
composition
during cholesterol period reasonably
agreeing with the values from the
literature
of gas data are well described by the
microscopic model
which demonstrates that the metabolic
flux model for oxygen uptake rate is
reasonable simplification
however sudden increase was observed in
both oxygen uptake rate and carbon
dioxide evolution
rate at the beginning of the methanol
induction causing disagreement between
mild prediction and experimental data
this means that the actual cell
metabolism was more focused
on energy metabolism and what was
predicted from the model
this may be due to dramatic changes in
cell metabolism for methanol adaptation
and finally with these results a
macroscopic biotin model with ph
and precipitation can be implemented and
compared with the entire bioterrorist
data
as shown in these plots
we can see that including precipitation
into the macroscopic part model
resulted in good agreement of mild
predictions and experimental data
of medium components and ph
while prediction for medium components
with ph and precipitation
can be also applied for improving the
chemically defined medium
this can be done by minimizing the
amount of the components needed
while still meeting cellular
requirements which is important for
extended operations and perfusion
furthermore the effects of primary
distributions estimated from the maximal
likelihood method
can be quantified by the probability
distribution function
the plots in this slide show the
probability distribution functions
constructed by monte carlo simulation
with 10 000 random primary sets sampled
from the primary distributions
we can see that the primary distribution
functions capture the run to run
variability in experimental
data especially for total protein and
ammonium concentration
sensitivity analysis identifies key
parameters for the states of interest
the plots in this slide show the
sensitivities of states of the
macroscopic biotin model
with respect to the related parameters
for example let's take a look into the
sensitivity of ammonium concentration
we can see that the ammonium
concentration is highly sensitive to
inlet-based concentration because of its
high concentration
and continuous input this indicates that
the inlet-based concentration should be
accurately identified
to apply the macroscopic model to the
experimental data
to conclude this work constructed on
extensive macroscopic bioreactor model
for pika pastores
describing substrates biomass 12 protein
other medium components of gas
components and ph
and while prediction from the
constructed model will describe the
experimental data with different
operating conditions
furthermore the probability distribution
of predictions from the primary
distribution
quantifies the wrong term variability
observed in the experimental data
with that i would like to acknowledge my
co-workers and funding source case
foundation
and also thank you all for your
attention